top lawmakers now on both sides of the
aisle are starting to ring alarm bells
about the threat of this drug shortage
here in the United States sources tell
me that as China is really tamping down
on the spread of the virus inside the
country this other new threat is now
just beginning to ramp up Fox Fox was
told by senator Rubio that about 80% of
the ingredients in drugs used here are
made abroad and that most of that 80% is
coming from China take a listen now we
don't know is there going to be
shortages we anticipate there will be in
certain drugs because those factories
have been shut down because of the virus
this worry does go all the way to the
top even President Trump himself has
brought this issue up he did so with
pharmaceutical execs over at the White
House he said his main goal here is to
bring manufacturing back to America he
said if that happens we can be much more
self-reliant on the drug ingredients
going forward pharmaceutical execs agree
with him the CEO of geo VAX
told me last weekend the vast majority
of drug ingredients today are made
either in China or in India he said it
is a national security issue here's the
rub though China rather than trying to
calm fears now is ratcheting up threats
this recent article came out in China's
state-run newspaper it's called Xinhua
it's basically the mouthpiece for the
Communist Party it claimed China might
impose pharmaceutical export controls
that had plunge America into quote the
mighty sea of the corona virus it's
important to cause to know that this
isn't really a hypothetical threat the
FDA has already announced a drug
shortage related to the corona virus
they haven't publicly said which drug
this is perhaps to quell fears and you
know incite some kind of a panic here
but there are already drugs that are in
short supply one that is dangerously in
short supply